it's been a little more than 24 hours
since the final u.s troops left
afghanistan but that's not the end of
the story obviously and this is not the
end of the war on terrorism national
security correspondent jennifer griffin
is at the pentagon tonight with that
good evening jennifer good evening brett
20 years ago the u.s military defeated
the taliban today the taliban rule
afghanistan once again and the u.s is
dependent on their goodwill to help
rescue americans and american allies who
remain stranded tonight
moments after the last u.s military
plane took off from kabul the taliban
took possession of the airport taking
photographs in american military
aircraft which had been disabled
carrying the weapons that the u.s
government bought for the afghan army
we're now closing a chapter
in our nation's history the last soldier
to leave marking the end of america's
20-year war major general chris donahue
commanding general of the 82nd airborne
division it was his fourth tour to
afghanistan his first was just after 9
11. our counterterrorism efforts in
afghanistan
and the region
for two decades
and saving the lives of
124 000 men women and children
evacuated the last 20 days
will ultimately
be the legacy among those left behind a
translator who spoke to the wall street
journal who says he rescued then senator
biden and two other u.s senators seen
here on a trip to afghanistan 13 years
ago when their helicopter was forced to
land in a snowstorm the interpreter is
not in this photo
hello mr president save me and my family
don't forget me here our message to him
is thank you for the role you played in
helping a number of my favorite people
out of a snowstorm and for all of the
work you did and our commitment is
enduring not just to american citizens
but to our afghan partners secretary of
state anthony blinken explained who some
of these american citizens that remain
in afghanistan are many are dual citizen
americans with deep roots and extended
families in afghanistan who've resided
there for many years many of the
americans left behind are babies with
u.s passports born to afghans with green
cards who gave birth in the u.s
those babies were dependent on parents
to get them to the airport and many of
these green card holders wanted to bring
a dozen or more non-american family
members with them and the taliban
blocked them now they await a more
dangerous rescue brett jennifer griffin
at the pentagon jennifer thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else